a promise made many times over I want
everybody to know there are no
circumstances in which I will ask
Brussels to delay we're leaving on the
31st of October no ifs or buts
Parliament told he would not tolerate
delay there are no circumstances in
which I will ever accept anything like
it whatever the cost
I'd rather be dead in a ditch today that
promise broken the Prime Minister right
into the EU to confirm a January 31st
extension brexit delayed a third time
the PM pinion on his poppy and trying to
pin the blame on Parliament not so much
dead in a ditch as stuck in a rut making
his case for a snap election but labour
won't give him one on his terms
waiver Prime Minister who will say
anything do anything to get his way
he will avoid his responsibilities break
his promises to dodge scrutiny and today
he wants an election and his bill well
not with our endorsement the ice to the
right 299 the nose to the left 70
failing to get the two-thirds majority
he needed but the PM not deterred we
will not allow this paralysis to
continue in one way or another we must
proceed straight to an election so to
plan B another election bill that will
pass if more than half of MPs vote for
it this house cannot any longer keep
this country hostage and an unlikely
coalition of Liberal Democrats and
Scottish nationalists could help the
prime minister Shepherd it through the
Commons we want an election we want the
people of Scotland to be given the
opportunity to have their say
that election mr. speaker on the right
of these Scottish people to determine
their own future Boris Johnson didn't
get his general election vote over the
line tonight but if he teams up with the
Liberal Democrats and the SNP there is
now a majority in parliament to pull the
trigger on a Christmas election will he
do it there are splits I understand in
number 10 and in cabinet over what to do
next some think that his best chance is
to go early have an election try and win
a majority and get brexit done by
January but others think that is really
high risk they think you should bring
back his brexit deal try and pass it in
November and then have a general
election next spring there hasn't been a
December general election in nearly a
century but it is closing in on
Parliament now the PM decided tonight
this is his preferred route the crucial
question is can he take enough MPs with
him
Beth Rigby Sky News Westminster